and now great moments and unintended
consequences
part one window wealth the year
1696 the problem britain needs money
the solution tax windows windows
increase with relative wealth and are
easily observed and verified from afar
a perfect revenue generator is born
sounds like a great idea with the best
of intentions
what could possibly go wrong to avoid
higher taxes
houses were built with fewer windows and
existing windows were bricked
up tenements were charged as single
dwellings putting them in a higher tax
bracket
which led to rising rents or windowless
apartments
the lack of ventilation and sunlight led
to greater disease
stunted growth and one rather irate
charles dickens
it took more than 150 years for
politicians to see the error of their
ways
perhaps because their view was blocked
by bricks
part two looney ladies the year
1992 the problem new dancing is
degrading to women and ruining the moral
fabric of alberta canada
the solution establish a one-meter
buffer zone between patrons and
dancers sounds like a total buzz kill
with puritanical intentions what could
possibly go wrong
it turns out that dancers earn most of
their money in the form of tips
and dollar bills don't fly through the
air very well
thus the measure designed to protect
dancers from degrading treatment
resulted in
the loony toss a creepy ritual where
naked women are pelted with canadian
dollar coins
way to make the ladies feel special
part 3 gallant grocers the year
2021 the problem local bureaucrats need
to look like they care
the solution mandate grocery stores
provide
hero pay to their workers sounds like a
great idea
with the best of intentions what could
possibly go
wrong never mind that these ordinances
may preempt federal labor and equal
protection laws
a 28 pay raise for employees can be
catastrophic to grocery stores that
traditionally operate
on razor thin margins as a result many
underperforming stores were closed
resulting in a hero pay of sudden
unemployment
don't spend it all in one place heroes
great moments and unintended
consequences
good intentions bad results